her performance in Chicago earned her a
Best Actress nomination for the second
year in a row
please welcome Renee Zellweger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
making movies is a cooperative venture
what if you were told at the start of
filming that your job was to enhance the
mood and the emotional content of just
about every scene but have nobody
noticed that you're doing it thankfully
the brilliant musicians who write the
musical scores for films proudly take on
that assignment and on Oscar night five
of them get the chance to be noticed
here are the nominees for Best Original
Score
catch me if you can by John Williams far
from heaven by Elmer Bernstein freedom
by Elliot Goldenthal
the hours by Philip Glass
Road to Perdition by Thomas Newman and
the Oscar goes to Elliot Goldenthal for
freedom
[Music]
this is the first Academy Award for
Elliot Goldenthal he's a four-time Oscar
nominee and is up for Best Original Song
tonight he was nominated in 1996 for
Michael Collins and in 94 for interview
with the vampire Wow to be around such
remarkable women Julie Taymor Salma
Hayek Sarah green Margie pranchi Oh
Thank You Miramax but I would really
want to say don't do it quickly is I
want to dedicate this award to the
bridges that we try to build to the
people of Mexico to the artistic
tradition and legacy a personal and
political art for you Mexico
[Applause]
[Music]